franchement, nous avons gagné cette élection,
je suis ici pour vous dire ce soir, nous pensons que
nous sommes sur la bonne voie pour gagner cette élection,
un groupe de personnes très triste
essaie de priver ce groupe
de personnes de leurs droits
et nous ne le tolérerons pas, ce n'est pas mon
endroit ou place de Donald Trump pour déclarer
qui a remporté cette élection, c'est la
décision du peuple américain,
mais je suis optimiste quant à ce résultat,
les résultats de ce soir ont été phénoménaux
et nous nous préparons, je veux dire
littéralement, nous étions juste tous prêts à
sortir et juste  célébrer quelque chose
qui était si beau si bon
un tel vote un tel succès les citoyens
de ce pays sont sortis
en nombre record c'est un record
il n'y a jamais rien eu de tel
pour soutenir notre incroyable mouvement nous
pensons que
l'un des réseaux a suggéré que nous '  j'ai
déjà gagné l'arizona mais nous sommes convaincus
de l'arizona
arizona nous avons beaucoup de vie là-dedans
et quelqu'un a dit que
quelqu'un a déclaré que c'était une victoire
pour nous et peut-être que ce sera je veux dire
que c'est possible nous venons aussi de
l'appeler du minnesota et nous  sommes toujours
dans le jeu en géorgie bien que ce
ne soit pas ce à quoi nous nous attendions
nous avons gagné la géorgie nous avons gagné le texas nous
gagnons la pennsylvanie par un
montant énorme
cela va prendre du temps pour compter les
votes nous allons gagner la pennsylvanie
donc la floride était un  formidable victoire
ohio un état formidable un grand état j'aime l'
ohio
caroline du nord grande victoire avec la caroline du nord
nous nous sentons vraiment bien à propos du wisconsin
et du michigan
nous gagnons le michigan mais je vais vous dire
j'ai regardé les chiffres j'ai dit bien
j'ai regardé  j'ai dit wow c'est beaucoup
et les gens vous m'avez entendu le dire avant
chaque fois que je sors de la maison de mon grand-père
à scranton il a crié joey
garde la foi et ma grand-mère quand
elle rit oh non joey répands-le
garde la foi les gars nous sommes  va gagner
ça merci merci merci
nous avons gagné des états et tout d'un coup
j'ai dit ce qui est arrivé à l'élection
c'est éteint
et nous avons tous ces annonceurs disant
ce qui s'est passé et puis ils ont dit oh
parce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
ils savaient qu'ils pouvaient  Je ne gagne pas alors ils ont dit
allons au tribunal et ai-je prédit ce
triton ai-je dit
cela je le dis depuis le jour où j'ai entendu dire
qu'ils allaient envoyer des dizaines
de millions de bulletins de vote j'ai dit exactement
parce que soit ils allaient  pour gagner ou
s'ils ne gagnent pas,
ils nous traîneront en justice c'est une fraude
envers le public américain c'est une
honte
pour notre pays nous nous préparions à
gagner cette élection
franchement nous avons gagné cette élection
donc nous serons  aller à la cour suprême des états-unis
nous voulons que tous les votes s'arrêtent
nous ne voulons pas qu'ils trouvent des bulletins de vote
à
quatre heures du matin et les ajoutent
à la liste d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est très triste c'est un moment très triste
pour moi, c'est un moment très triste
et
nous allons gagner cela et en ce qui me
concerne, nous en avons déjà un que nous
savions à cause du
vote anticipé sans précédent lors d'un vote par correspondance
qui va prendre un certain temps, nous allons
devoir être patient
jusqu'à ce que le travail acharné des votes italiens
soit terminé
et ce n'est pas fini tant que chaque vote n'est pas
compté, chaque bulletin est compté